[Musique]
avec wohlen phrase bonjour hélène bon je
peux lire à la une de la presse ce matin
les accusations des états unis qui
affirme que la russie veut annexer dans
les jours à venir je cite les provinces
séparatistes de donetsk et de louhansk à
l'est de l'ukraine d'après le washington
post la russie chercheur est également à
organiser vers la mi-mai des référendums
pour tenter d'apporter je cite un vernis
démocratique à ces élections un projet
semblable on s'en souvient à ce qui
s'est passé en crimée en 2014 selon les
états unis un tel scénario aurait pour
but pour objectif l'installation dans
ces régions de dirigeants fidèles à
moscou au risque évidemment d'entraîner
le conflit dans une phase imprévisible
plus explosive encore de son côté
l'union européenne tente de répliquer à
cette invasion russe par un renforcement
des sanctions contre moscou un nouveau
train de mesures devraient être adoptées
dès demain d'après le financial times
l'allemagne se dit prête désormais à
soutenir à l'embargo sur le pétrole
russe synonyme néanmoins pour les
consommateurs européens d'une hausse des
prix de l'énergie au coût économique
considérable des européens qui se ruent
désormais vers le gaz naturel liquéfié
américain dont le coût environnemental
est également très élevé puisque le gnl
est en moyenne deux fois et demie de
plus simple de co2 que le gaz qui est
transporté par des tuyaux et pour le gaz
de schiste américain qui arrive donc par
bateau c'est encore pire prévient le
quotidien la croix
la guerre en ukraine hélène faut-il le
rappeler dont la simple évocation en
russie est passible de 15 ans de prison
face à la censure du kremlin s'est
beaucoup de médias russes ont été
contraints de fermer parmi eux le
journal novaïa gazeta dont le rédacteur
en chef colauréat du nobel de la paix
2021 s'est entretenu avec le journal
suisse le temps à l'occasion vous l'avez
évoqué de la journée mondiale de la
liberté de la presse dans cet entretien
dmitri mouratov affirme que lorsqu'on
parle à poutine des valeurs de
l'occident ça le fait mourir de rire je
le cite que le président russe droite au
commerce pas aux valeurs et que son pays
avait un avenir mais que beaucoup de ses
compatriotes pensent qu'il n'en a plus à
la une est également hélène dans la
presse l' annonce hier par le
gouvernement espagnol que les téléphones
du premier ministre et de la ministre de
la défense sont eux aussi étaient
infectés par pegasus le logiciel espion
israélien dont on a beaucoup parlé mais
le ps indique que l'exécutif dit ignorer
par qui ces téléphones auraient été
espionnées mais précise qu'une partie de
ces intrusions se serait produite en mai
2021 c'est à dire au moment où l'espagne
on s'en souvient été confronté à
l'arrivée de milliers de migrants dans
l'enclavé espagnole de ceuta au maroc ce
qui avait alors été considéré comme un
moyen pour rabat de faire pression sur
le gouvernement espagnol dans le conflit
du sahara occidental
mai 2021 ce fut aussi le moment où le
gouvernement espagnol était en
négociation avec les indépendantistes
catalans au sujet de possibles grâce à
accorder ou non à des responsables
catalans emprisonner les leaders
indépendantistes catalans dont les
téléphones hors est également été
affecté par pegasus le quotidien catalan
la vanguardia évoque à propos des
dernières révélations d'espionnage sur
les téléphones de pedro sanchez et de sa
ministre de la défense impossible écran
de fumée dispersés par le gouvernement
pour détourner l'attention du public de
l'espionnage précisément des
indépendantistes catalans qui eux
demandent désormais la mise en place
d'une commission d' enquête indépendante
en france pas d'espionnage mais d'aucuns
aimeraient sans doute être une petite
souris pour écouter les négociations
entre la france insoumise le parti
communiste et le parti socialiste il ya
beaucoup de spéculations toujours autour
de ces négociations qui se poursuivent
donc on en a parlé à l'instant pour
tenter de parvenir à un accord en vue
des législatives du mois de juin d'après
l'alliance conclue dimanche avec les
écologistes la france insoumise le pc et
le ps serait tout près du but d'après
l'humanité qui évoque déjà un
rassemblement historique s'il vient
évidemment à se concrétiser l'histoire
avec un grand h
invoquée par la marseillaise quotidien
local qui se demandent si la france
s'apprête à assister au retour du front
populaire à la grande coalition des
partis de gauche qui avait gouverné la
france de 1936 à 1938 l'ops du coup
essayent d'imaginer jean luc mélenchon
dans le costume de léon blum à figure du
socialisme et président du conseil sous
le front populaire
de léon blum ou plutôt dans la peau de
jules césar imaginez le patron de la
france insoumise juché sur son trône
triomphant le pouce levé hésitantes à
user de son pouvoir de vie et de mort
sur ses malheureux concurrents tous en
état de mort clinique venant tape
l'aurait le pardon et la grâce du nouvel
empereur de la gauche
on a évoqué ici vous en souvenez pauline
il ya peu de temps
l'équipée sauvage de deux bambins de 2
ans souvient en espagnol s'étaient
enfuis de leur crèche sur leurs motos en
plastique le guardian fait état ce matin
d'une fugue du même genre cette fois ça
se passe aux pays bas où un petit gars
de quatre ans a réussi à s'emparer des
clés de la voiture de ses parents et à
s'enfuir à bord du véhicule après avoir
parcouru quelques mètres et embouti deux
voitures le petit garçon pauline a été
retrouvé errant dans la rue en pyjama
mais tout à fait sain et sauf figurez
vous que la police néerlandaise a
déclaré avec humour avoir découvert un
nouveau max verstappen le champion du
monde de 2021 de formula qui est
d'origine belgo néerlandaise ben c'est
l'avenir qu'on lui souhaite à ce petit
garçon à merci beaucoup allen c'était la
revue de presse à tout à l'heure dans
paris direct jeu